(beeping)
(lively piano music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal.
Naked.
Large-brained.
Long the master of fire,
tools, and language.
But still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable.
Yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are,
and how we got here.
An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
(ambient music)
(uptempo music)
- I do study chimpanzees in a savanna
and I'd like to tell you
a little bit more about that site
because it does have a lot of
importance as far as the
chimpanzees' hunting behavior goes.
And this map I will show you,
most of the long-term
chimpanzee study sites
operating today, not all of them,
but these sites most
of them here have been
ongoing for at least 10 years
and in some cases and the
case of Gombe and Mahale
more than 50 years.
And so, most of you are probably
familiar with Jane Goodall
and at least the person,
but Gombe is the site that
she helped to establish
that Ian talked about.
I'm across the continent
and I'm over in West Africa,
this is my site, the Fongoli study site.
And I chose this site
because it is in a savanna
and we think that our lineage,
evolutionarily speaking
evolved in this type of habitat
and so, I'll show you
some images from the site.
My underlying questions have to do with
how these chimpanzees differ
from chimpanzees living in forests,
like the chimps we've heard about before
and in Goualougo and in Gombe.
And I will cite Jim Moore here,
he's written a lot about using chimpanzees
as what we call a referential model
and that is comparing them to
chimpanzees living in a forested site.
And the assumption is that
the environment will have
effects on their behavior.
And I did think this going in,
I had ideas about what
the differences might be
and the chimps kind of went their own way
and showed me a lot more
differences including hunting,
and so I'll talk to you about that today.
So though I'm going to talk
about three main questions
and I focus on the types of hunting
or aspects of the Fongoli
chimpanzees' hunting
that you don't necessarily
see at other sites
or that are very rare.
And so one of the things
that we see here commonly
is that chimpanzees hunt with tools
and that's something that we
use to define our own species.
It has been seen literally
a handful of times
at another site in Tanzania
but at Fongoli chimpanzees
do this quite frequently
so we've seen hundreds of cases now
and I'll talk to you more about that.
So one of the questions that I'll touch on
is why hunt with tools in
this particular habitat?
Something else that is not really common
at other chimpanzee
sites is that in fact in
regarding this particular type of hunting,
females are more frequently going to be
those hunting with
tools compared to males,
and as we heard that's just not the case
in most other chimpanzee study sites
so I'll talk more about that.
And then to follow up with David's talk
I will talk about meat sharing
or I use the word sharing
and I'll talk about how I define that,
but I'll specifically talk
about how females dole out meat.
And then finally I'll come
back to this idea about
using chimpanzees as a model
and what perhaps the Fongoli
chimpanzees that I study
can help us say or think about in terms of
the evolution of early hominin
or bipedal ape hunting.
So these are some images
from my study site,
the Fongoli study site
is one of the hottest,
driest and most vegetatively
open sites that you see today
where chimpanzees have
actually been habituated
to a human presence.
So this took us quite a long time,
it took us four years.
I started in 2001 and we
habituated males to our presence
by 2005 but I wasn't able to identify
all the chimpanzees in
the group until 2006.
That's when we identified all the females,
this is a view of my
pretty fancy camp there.
And hopefully that gives you
some idea of the vegetation.
So it's a woodland savanna,
the dominant understory
is grass the savanna
but you do have a large proportion
of the habitat as woodlands.
Over half of the habitat is woodland
and only a very small portion is forest,
about 3% of the habitat is forest
and this is where you
find your water sources.
This is really the chimpanzees'
most limiting resource
at Fongoli is water.
Temperatures are incredibly hot,
really hot for me, even hot for chimps.
So right now we're, well,
yeah, the month of March in Senegal is
almost approaching the
peak of the dry season
so temperatures are regularly
over a hundred degrees.
They may get up to 115 or so.
During the rainy season
or at least at the beginning
of the rainy season
you find some relief
because the trees will
put out leaves again.
They lose all their trees
during the dry season.
But yet you have this lag,
you have hot temperatures
and then you have this high
humidity which is really fun.
And so, literally the heat
index in June is around 120, 125
and that's when I take students out.
(audience laughing)
So a little bit about
the Fongoli study group.
Within this particular habitat
they have a very large
home range, 110 kilometers,
which is one of the largest
if not the largest so far described.
The community size is relatively small,
it's not the smallest
chimpanzee community studied
but it's on the small
size, around 35 chimps.
And importantly we have
a sex ratio that is
sort of the opposite of
what you see at other sites.
So we have more males than females,
that's usually not the case.
And the data that I'm
gonna talk about today
stem from 2005 through 2017.
One other thing I'll say about adult males
versus adult females is
because of the fact that
when I first got to Fongoli
I heard that even though chimpanzees
are not eaten at the site
and this is not within a national park,
this is outside of a national park
so you do have villages in the area.
Anthropogenic or human
disturbance accounts
for about 5% of the habitat.
You do have chimpanzees
living alongside people,
they're not habituated to them,
they're habituated to us so we're okay
but other people are not.
But in rare cases you do have people
that will try to hunt a chimpanzee
in order to get a female's
infant for the pet trade
and we had that happen
one time in 17 years.
And because of that I focus on adult males
as my focal subjects.
The Fongoli community is often
together as one large group
so I can collect data on females,
but they are more timid
when they're by themselves
and I don't try to follow them
when they're by themselves.
So I think I know a lot about
what is going on with males
and I know some about what
is going on with females
but perhaps not as much.
So this pie chart gives you an idea
of the prey species consumed
by Fongoli chimpanzees
both by males and by females.
And as Ian pointed out
there are no colobus monkeys
in this particular habitat.
So it is a savanna woodland habitat,
colobus monkeys don't occur here.
Forest guenons like red-tailed monkeys
or other colobus monkeys, blue
monkeys do not occur here.
Instead you have savanna
species like baboons,
patas monkeys, vervets.
You have mongooses,
bushbucks, things like this.
And then on the very lower right
you see that adorable little bush baby
and Ian introduced the galago as well.
The galago is actually
the main prey species
of Fongoli chimpanzees,
both males and females,
and this is the animal
that they hunt with tools
and I'll actually hopefully
show you some video of that
and talk more about that.
So the prey profile if
you wanna call it that
really reflects the
savanna type of habitat
and it does also support
as Ian pointed out
or talked about what is
called a risk-averse strategy.
So I'm just going to show you some video
and try to narrate it here.
So this is tool-assisted hunting.
What this image is gonna show you
is an adult female
that's if you can't tell,
that's Farafa, she's an older female.
We estimate her age to be around 40.
She's one of the top female
hunters in the group.
So she's trying to get at these
adorable little bush babies
that try to sleep in
cavities during the day
until this rude chimpanzee
comes with the tool.
That's an adult male, that's Jumpkin
and he goes about it a
little bit differently.
(audience laughing)
And so, even though
females hunt with tools
more than expected,
I'll talk a little bit
more about that next,
males do exhibit this type
of hunting behavior as well.
(audience laughing)
I have to say he's
usually better than that.
(audience laughing)
They just caught him on a bad day.
Well, we'll let Jumpkin try one more time.
(audience laughing)
If you didn't guess he wasn't successful
in this particular bout.
So we're looking at a lot of
different aspects of this.
Well.
(audience laughing)
I almost feel bad showing that.
We're looking at a lot
of different aspects
of this particular behavior
and so this is a juvenile female, Vivian,
that was her mother that was hunting.
And the juveniles start this behavior
when they're about two years of age,
when they're still infants and nursing
but they don't learn really the proper
tool length and that sort of thing
until they get to be about four.
So she gets a little frustrated too.
(audience laughing)
All right, enough fun I guess.
So in terms of our results so far,
I apologize because in your
abstract I put over 500,
I was sure that we would
hit the 500 mark this year.
499, I just can't believe it.
(audience laughs)
But we have 499 hunting records,
those aren't all successes
and that's including adults and immatures.
We've only seen adolescent
and adult individuals
successful in this type
of hunting behavior.
Like I said infants begin to exhibit it
and they do really good
as far as making the tool
but they don't make a proper tool
until they get to be a juvenile.
So we see about 32 hunts
per year on average
when you take into account
that there are some days
that we can't be there,
the river's too high
or someone's sick.
We think that they probably
hunt at least 50 times a year.
And again, our most recent
analysis suggest that
females do hunt significantly
more than expected with tools
even though males also hunt.
And we did analysis taking into account
not only their membership in
the the community as a whole
but also their membership
and so-called hunting parties
or parties that the chimpanzees
are in on those days.
So I want to talk a little bit more about
just the hunters themselves
and this is a lot of color there
but I wanted to show you the
top 10 hunters at Fongoli
and also the different types of foods
or prey that they hunt.
And so, you have two
females that are actually
among the top 10 hunters at Fongoli.
Interestingly I think is
that both of those females,
females are very high-ranking.
So Tumbo there is
currently our alpha female
based on these very
stylized pant grunt records,
sorry, vocalizations
and we keep records of these vocalizations
where a subordinate individual will
pant grunt to a dominant individual.
And Tumbo actually overtook
that alpha position
from Farafa there about two years ago.
And so, females actually do
hunt some in this community
or at least enough to be considered
among the top 10 Fongoli hunters.
And also I'd like to point out that
we have a tie right now
for the very top hunter
and one is the alpha male, that's David.
He is tied for the top
hunting position with Siberut
and some of you will be
happy to know that Siberut
who is pictured there is not only
the oldest hunter in the
group, he's oldest male
but he's also the lowest
ranking male as well.
And then if you look at female
hunting behavior in general
females, almost all females hunt
and almost all males hunt as well
so they hunt about what you would expect
or at least their participation
in hunting overall
is what you would expect based
on their their membership
in the Fongoli community.
I wanted to look, talk a little
bit about Fongoli hunting
and the context of female
hunting across study sites.
So, Ian talked about that some
and I've used data from
his work and others
to look at Fongoli female hunting
and in fact, there are females elsewhere
that also engage in
quite a bit of hunting.
In fact, females at
Mahale hunt a little more
than females at Fongoli if you look at
Fongoli female hunting behavior overall.
And then when you look at tool use
you see that Fongoli
females do hunt quite a bit
almost half of the tool-assisted hunting
at Fongoli is by females.
And again remember that we
have fewer females at Fongoli,
we don't follow females
systematically like we do males.
And so one question as to why females hunt
is basically as David started out with,
you know, it's probably no surprise that
the chimps gained a lot
of nutrition from hunting,
but I think perhaps a more
interesting question is
why females don't hunt
more at other sites.
And Ian talked about some
of these issues as well
that I'll pursue right now.
And so, if you looked
at for example theft,
there's not a lot of theft at Fongoli
so when I use the word share
I'm referring to basically
the last three categories I
think that David talked about.
So active food transfer
but not theft, right,
and passive food transfer, et cetera.
So I consider theft to
be a different category
and at Fongoli you have very little theft.
The only thought we've seen involves
two different alpha males,
so very little theft.
Whereas at other sites you
do have quite a bit of theft
and so I believe as Ian said,
females don't have incentive
to hunt at some sites.
At Fongoli there definitely is incentive
and not only females but this
is a little video of again
that lower-ranking male.
So out of 13 males he's number 13.
He's the oldest male, that's Siberut.
So he's walking by a number of adult males
with this bushbuck fawn that he's captured
and no one makes any
attempt to take it from him.
He had actually been eating
on that fawn for over an hour
and he had a number of
individuals sitting around
basically begging, he
didn't share with them.
And as he moves off
you'll see that there's
another older male that will follow him
and this is his ally Bandit.
Where's Bandit?
There he is.
Calmly following his buddy Siberut out.
And so, he did end up sharing with Bandit.
So not only do you see
some sort of concept
well, I hate to say concept of ownership
but you see tolerance.
So tolerance of possession of prey
by dominant males of these
low ranking individuals,
females and also lower ranking males.
So I think that at
Fongoli you actually have
the incentive to hunt.
It's one of the reasons that
you see so much hunting,
at least tool-assisted hunting in females.
I wanna show it a slightly different way.
So, these are the same top 10 hunters
but rather than being expressed
in the number of prey that they brought in
this is the number of kilograms
or estimated kilograms of meat, right?
And so, you see that David has jumped up
to number one position there.
It depends on what you hunt
and almost everybody hunts
bush babies except K.L.,
we've never seen him capture a bush baby.
But what's interesting is you see that
the third top hunter there
at least in terms of prey captures,
Lupin has fallen quite low
because he does seem to
specialize on bush babies.
So the females really didn't
change positions at all,
they're still in the top 10
but you do see a lot of variation.
So that's something that
we're looking at now
and so, I wanted to talk
just a little bit about
what females can provide in
terms of transfer or sharing.
And we, so far this is still
preliminary to some degree.
We've looked at sharing or
food transfer by females
and again I'm considering
David's categories
of active transfer, passive transfer
and scrounging but tolerated scrounging,
and I'm not considering a theft
in this category in females
actually shared with other individuals
more often they did with their offspring.
So that's something that
we're exploring right now.
And basically I would argue that females
as Rebecca has pointed out
should be considered as well
and finally I'll just
move on to my last slide
and leave you with a couple of thoughts.
First of all I think
Travis Pickering said it
probably better than I can.
So, he actually thinks that if you
think about the tool-assisted
hunting at Fongoli
it perhaps can tell us more about
some of the early hominin
hunting that went on
compared to the emotionally-charged
hunting of chimpanzees
as he puts it.
And I'll just end up by saying
echoing what Rebecca has said
as well about female humans
is that just now
and I think Richard
mentioned this as well,
we're beginning to understand
more about female chimpanzee hunting,
and that they also play
a part in this scenario.
So, thank you very much.
(audience applauding)
(uptempo music)